welcome back to another episode of worth
it one that you probably
were never expecting because we're doing
oil first off
oil is an essential part of
almost all cooking two these are also
all
oils that you can buy online and have
shipped to the us
i have the oils in my possession i'm
bringing them to you guys that sounds
great so today on worth it we're going
to be trying
three different oils at three
drastically different price points to
find out which oil
is the most worth it at its price on
this show we usually like to start with
a pretty low price point but today we're
featuring
three really delicious oils the first
oil
is actually 18 and it's a chili oil
chili oils are my top one favorite oil
yeah so to start off we're going to be
talking with max and wendy
the owners of boon sauce
i run boon sauce with my fiancee wendy
right now
i'm in bangkok i'm the executive pastry
chef for blue by alan du pass
boone started as a hobby and kind of a
passion project for max
he grew up eating really spicy and he
also grew up eating a lot of chili oil
but he always kind of
was missing the heat and the flavor from
the chili oils i've cooked my whole
entire life i went through this phase
where i wanted to eat chili oil i'd go
to cantonese restaurants eat chow
fun just so like any chili oil with it i
just decided like one day like hey why
don't
i just make my own like i would adjust
it according to my dad's taste i was
like oh it needs to be spicier he would
give jars to his friends and family they
would ration the jars that they had
waiting for max to cook the next batch
so i just started making bigger and
bigger batches
we have a co-packer we pretty much make
our sauce out of their commissary
kitchen i feel like every ingredient
its flavor is peak at a certain
temperature we start the shallots first
just because i love
the flavor of shallots and oil like
caramelized then after we'll put the
garlic in
just because i don't want to caramelize
as much it needs to be spicy enough like
i don't taste enough chili oils that are
like spicy and hot the spices prickly
ash
fennel seeds the last stuff is the
chilis you don't want it to cook too
much
just enough to kind of get them crisped
up and
kind of help release the flavor and
spiciness into it and
also like i just wanted like a lot of
umami in it without it being like funky
and usually we let the sauce sit around
two weeks because if you taste the sauce
right when it's made you'll be confused
like oh it's not really that flavorful
and then you taste it like a week after
you're like oh shoot now i get it
like i don't really eat that much
chinese food so like i want like the
chili oil to be like placed on other
foods that i usually eat
my mouth is already watering
anticipation of the spice
cheers just putting oil in our mouths
oh dear wow this is this is what's
happening in my mouth right now
wow that felt like a bite of real
solid food it absolutely did wendy and
max
had some of their favorite ways that
they enjoy boon sauce that they
recommended to us when chick-fil-a had
their
chicken salad sandwich i'd always get
that just so i can put chili oil on it
so we made
max's favorite chicken salad oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
magnificent work man oh my god
it actually works really well with these
salad type sandwiches because
it just disintegrates into the meat the
oil
is almost more savory than the chicken
salad you know
what this reminds me of snoop dogg and
martha stewart
a hundred percent you got two people who
on paper you would never sit together
i also love to eat it with tuna fish
sandwiches alright let's go tuna now
sandwich number two
[Applause]
i gotta start with wendy here the boon
sauce is already a little fishy
right and then just adding the tuna on
there this is just a cheat code
like yeah i'm not a good chef and i'm
just like enter boon sauce
the flavor is really italian to me
something about the
fennel the onion thing of which
also costco pizza it's kind of gross but
i kind of like putting qb mayonnaise
drizzle the lines and then you just top
with
chili oil it sounds gross but it's
pretty good i'm ready let's go
boom oh god oh my goodness
cheers stephen
okay it's the mayo plus the boon sauce
together
if you can get behind ranch on pizza
this is effectively the same thing
i am pleasantly surprised that this was
max's
favorite thing to do with boon sauce
because he works at all these really
prestigious restaurants is it insane
yes it is delicious also yes
i didn't think there could be that much
range in a chili oil
i like the word to use their range all
right i think it's time for
a wonderful oil fact during an economic
depression in the 1870s procter and
gamble had to find a way to reduce the
cost of raw ingredients
including animal fats in their bars of
soap their solution to this
is what eventually led to the greatest
dietary shift in the history of the us
switching from using animal fats to
vegetable oil
to cook really maybe we should be
cooking with more
animal fat i do think that there's a
benefit to vegetable oil which is the
fact that it's just
healthier to begin with i think you
think those things
because of procter and gamble oh
so andrew what oil are you bringing to
my residence next
our next oil is going to be an olive oil
we're going to be speaking with
giuseppe and skylar the founders of
exile olive oil
they're based in the us but they're
currently over in calabria italy
for their olive harvest okay so i'll see
you in italy
ciao
[Music]
we are the founders of exile olive oil
calabrese famous for olive oil
my grandfather planted a bunch of olive
trees and
from there my family kept this
harvesting
time they didn't do just for living they
did just for
remember the memory of my grandfather so
we just started harvest
the best time of the year we're out
there
in the trees and you have to put nets
down so with extra virgin olive oil you
don't want to take the olives that are
on the ground
you want as fresh olives as possible you
then take a branch shaker
and that is going to shake the olives
off of that branch into the net we're
harvesting in the morning and we're
trying to get to the press as quickly as
possible it's kind of like a race
there are 650 cultivars which means a
cultivated varietal each of them has a
particular taste
which removes all the leaves we don't
talk about
olive oil as much as we talk about wine
so you want to look for a harvest date
which is different than a bottle date if
they have an acidity level on the back
of the bottle that's bonus point
brand should be pretty transparent about
their acidity levels
because that is one of the rules that
you have to follow in making extra
virgin olive oil
and really it doesn't technically expire
however it does go rancid for me
16 months is the shelf life if you have
olive oil in your pantry right now
that is over a year old like use it
there's no time like the present i just
realized
and this is a really stupid observation
but it's just
olives there's nothing else in there
it's wild right
we're in a part of italy that is growing
a bunch of
cultivars that other people don't even
know about but
oftentimes it's used as like bulk olive
oil so they're not honoring the olives
that are grown here but we have to
let calabrian oil be calabrian oil
otherwise it's getting lost
and that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to bring it back i want it to be
a nice product that people are really
going to enjoy and love
honor your family's heritage
i'm very excited for this buying nice
olive oil is something i've always
thought about but never brought myself
to do
because sometimes it's hard to tell the
difference between good and bad olive
oil there's a very proper way to taste
it's similar to tasting wine if you have
a tall shot glass those are really good
because
there's enough space for you kind of
like smell the olive oil i love how
the go-to olive oil tasting for all of
us
has been sake last year we covered like
this and we keep
in the palm process to reach the
temperature of our body
so i'm warming up with my palm so once
you are
ready you just do a little twist like
this
in order to make the olive oil going to
the
side of the cup twisting it along the
side
like a scent and a record with your mind
your library
all the flavor that you can get putting
that one in the mind library
it is kind of perfumey it's a rather
tame smell though it was it
and after you do stripe so you're
sucking through your teeth
and the oil will spray onto the back of
your throat can be very spicy for some
people that spiciness on the back of
your throat those are polyphenols and
that's what you want
polyphenols which are antioxidants which
are so good for you hello anti-aging
we all want to look like sophia loren
right
oh wow oh my gosh oh there goes the
spice in my throat now
it's almost like leathery it was like
weathering like leathery
definitely transformed in a way i did
not expect over time
it's crazy how often we cook with olive
oil and we don't
do this process when you have a dinner
and you're going to pair
a bottle of wine with what you're going
to eat
the same is the olive oil i really
recommend for
pasta with just simple tomato heat olive
oil
ash an entire garlic clove throw that
into the oil add in
diced tomatoes you want to let the
tomatoes melt add the pasta in
stir stir stir you can add your grated
parmesan reggiano and add like a
teaspoon and a half
of olive oil on top all right cheers
steven
oh man magnificent mine tastes way
better than yours
just leave my virtual apartment
i mean this feels stupid to say but you
can really taste the olive
taste on the pasta the healthy portion
of olive oil on top so just
add that like thing that you need it's
that third element
it's amazing how much you can get out of
doing
one thing the right way every lifetime
needs a giuseppe and skylar like they
need
the person who is going to care about
olive oil so much that everybody else in
the world can enjoy it
the word of this episode i think is
drizzle
adam oil fact oil paints don't actually
dry they oxidize causing them to harden
water dries out right and oil and water
there couldn't be two things more
different than each other so if water
dries out
oil doesn't dry out wait do you have any
other information about oil paint
before the 14th century oil colors were
made with pigment ground into
an emulsion with egg here's the real
question though
does egg dry i think it does or does it
oxidize
no well maybe both actually or does it
congeal
or did it come after the chicken
so for our final oil we're visiting
marco and michael
at truffle brothers they are the truffle
brothers we're gonna be checking out
their
truffle slices preserved in oil
sometimes i see comments
that say oh the expensive food is just a
regular food that they threw truffles on
top
well this episode might be the purest
form
of that idea because it is quite
literally truffles in oil
when we arrived here 20 years ago we
want to do
eventually tasting place for chefs
we do people love the food that we make
we have this store in front of all spa
salomeria by truffle brothers we have a
lot of product we have a black truffle
oil we have a truffle salt
we have a lot of ingredients people love
it and how did you two
get started with truffles we start
when we teenagers when we have a 10 12
years old
we go together with the dogs who found
the truffle
in the forest we have a decent bullet
raffle maybe work with two hundred
dollars
if the guys give our fifty dollars for
fifty dollars to
ten years all the kids we go to school
they buy pizza for all his
friends we feel rich you know before the
coffee do we supply more to 300
wrestling in los angeles
right now a little bit less about we
supply from the fine dining restaurant
providence espargo middle east the
truffle seasoning the best
time of the year we buy a lot we slice
the truffle
and we put in the oil from the fresh a
lot of people frozen
for this reason people love it our
product we don't want to use to sell a
truffle
the the customer go home they can cook
with the wrong ingredient
for us you put you want to put in the
steak
or in the pasta when you mix pasta
the truffle in the oil is very good
everybody have different
approach with the truffle but every time
we try
our product in different restaurant
we've always be
impressed
[Music]
here we are the final taste test all
right let's take a little sniff of the
truffle
oh that is truffle yeah instead of not
taking a shower for
a year it's like it's been showering for
a year in this oil so truffle brothers
if you're getting these truffle slices
in oil instead of
for example a filet mignon with fresh
truffle we're using a flank steak with
our truffle slices and instead of a
really nice
pasta we have box mac and cheese with
truffle slices in oil not to be confused
by the way
with truffle oil because you're getting
actual
chunks of truffle cheers cheers
what else do i say that's really good
it's surprisingly good
the noodles they all taste like truffle
i mean and we had truffle mac and cheese
that came out of a lobster's carcass
and i'm kind of like you know what the
amy's bunny mac and cheese is kind of
doing it for me
let's move on to the steak cheers
[Music]
when you're biting the steak and the
juices are coming out of the meat you're
incorporating the truffle
in your mouth which is interesting
instead of like cooking it on the stove
with it
it's almost like a shortcut to making a
mushroom sauce for a steak
if you want to have a travel experience
without going to a restaurant this is
absolutely a way to do that especially
if you live in a place that you know
restaurants don't have truffle or in a
city where it's not widely served i feel
like this is a bad dream that i've had
where somebody surprises me by coming
over to my house
and i'm just like out of stuff to make
an impressive meal for them
but if i had one of these suckers yeah
suddenly you got a world-class dish
adam came over i'd be like oh no i gotta
make something good for him because
i know he's gonna be judging me
today we ate the maybe the weirdest
collection of foods i've ever eaten on
the show and i have zero regrets
i learned a lot of useful information
about
cooking name one thing you learned today
that you're gonna be applying to your
cooking for the rest of your life
mayonnaise on pizza
oh andrew ilnicki
adam bianchi and stephen lim what oil
was the most worth it to you at a given
price point my worth at winner
i'm gonna give it to boon sauce like i
think putting that
on not meat can give you a similar
satisfaction
to eating meat and i think that's a
really powerful thing truffle
brothers was very interesting flavor
wise i really enjoyed a boon the most
am i worth a winner today and it's my
own criteria so i get to choose
it's exile giuseppe's family from many
many years ago
planted these olive trees and we get to
experience
the fruits of that love and labor adam
who's your wife winner
exo whoa well that's it for now
worth it is out for the year feel free
to enjoy these oils on your own at home
you can buy them send them to your
friends as holiday presents
and andrew adam it's been good seeing
you guys the fact that we got to hang
out in person at that picnic
oh that was nice it was delightful
that's it for now thank you for watching
and happy eating happy eating
[Music]
you